i wouldn't get excited about starting
the stream because we're only gonna
i suppose we should
we'll give it we'll give it a moment to
fire up slightly urine's law
welcome along to this extraordinary
meeting of the performance policy and
partnerships committee um and apologies
for the delay uh we've
theoretically got uh mrs coote joining
us on zoom shortly uh but we have
apologies from both councillor abbott
and councillor skit if somebody wants to
move that though sorry counselor skelt
skid
sorry peter
i've created your new brother they gave
me the skitter scene
did you have some christmas cake
three
you'll be pinging
oh sorry counselor abbott and councillor
skill would somebody like to move their
receipt councillor lewis and miss cook
put that all in favor
against carried a couple of late items
um to receive
eventually maybe the late item of the
annual report but we'll deal with that
uh
in committee or now might mr day
thank you through yourself the chair it
would be my recommendation to the
committee to
hand back the delegation
relation to that late item through to
council
so just to clarify that'll mean that uh
the initial discussion will be at risk
and assurance and then council can go
back after that and receive the report
that is correct yeah so i'm happy to
move in that direction that we hand back
delegation to full council councillor
emerson
seconding
it's open for discussion
there is none i put the motion all in
favor aye against
carried that was a lot quicker than i
was expecting for the annual report
sadly
major late item for public excluded is
the uh inclusion of the next step for
the city block proposal for consultation
in january
and as
with the previous meeting the item came
to hand after the agenda was published
somebody want to move that that's
accepted
counselor sopa
and councillor amundsen
put that
against
carried silence
rained and we all got whipped
um
some changes to the public excluded
reasoning for
um
tenure
just are we just noting that um yes mr
chair if you could note in public that
the reason given on the agenda of
section 2 section 7 2 f i
should in fact be section 7 2 f 2
so that rather than being free and frank
it is to protect officers from improper
pressure
thank you
so with that note and those changes i'm
happy to move that we go into public
excluded
uh fourteen new and the next steps for
the reasons as outlined including that
change for tn news
you